have you ever met Elizabeth Warren uh
uh I think about that I don't think so
you did if you did would you ask her a a
I don't even know how to say this this
story is so weird what do you mean just
get it out Tim just get out on the plane
to New Hampshire the night of the Iowa
caucuses Warren said quote everyone
comes up to me and says I would vote for
you if you had a penis oh yeah you know
I did say that
yeah that now now that you remind me yes
but everyone was saying it yeah no well
because no because everyone is saying it
so I just yeah of course I'm going to
follow the crowd yeah yeah you're not
gonna not say that Elizabeth Warren okay
this is such a weird statement like what
what did she say this in the context too
I it's like she's trying to assert
patriarchy and misogyny or whatever oh
okay right a nonsense statement I'd like
you all to just consider this for a
second she said everyone quits a quote
everyone comes up to me and says I would
vote for you if you had a penis that
means there are old women going up to
her and going I'm a big fan of literally
fire and I vote for you if you had a
penis I really don't think that's
happening I really don't think
everyone so like an 18 year old guy
walks up to her and says that to her
will you also see this though with and
this this might be to give you I'll
throw you Boney and this is a little
identitarian
um even though it's about gender because
they're trying to act as if you're
you're reproductive organs are the only
difference between men and women
like this this you know the physical
external attributes are the only
difference whatsoever there are no
biochemical differences there's no
spiritual differences there's no
physical difference other than that
which we can see imagine if you had
um in your local community there's a
very serious problem with pickle jars
okay yeah all right right well I am
Polish well well there you go yes and
now it's it's someone might actually go
close with one and be like I'd vote for
it if you had a penis because can she
open pickle jars for the pub
well you remember Hillary remember
Hillary's the Pickled pickle gate right
no the Jimmy Kimmel you don't remember
this this was the whole okay so in 2016
Hillary's Health was the big Meme and
everybody kept saying what's up with
Hillary's Mel health and then there was
the problem with Hillary stools and
because Hillary would always appear on
stage with a stool so we were talking
about hashtag Hilary stools Hillary's
stools are appearing everywhere Hillary
whenever Hillary appeal appears Hillary
stool will appear with her and then
everybody was saying that she can't get
through an event without without having
to sit down at some point so she goes on
Jimmy Kimmel people forget how crazy
2016 was she goes on Jimmy Kimmel and he
kind of brings all of this up and says
he goes Madam Secretary would you would
you would you open this pickle jar for
us and then she does and they make this
big meme out of it but then it comes out
that the pickle jar was actually
pre-opened of course even before she did
all this no it was a staged it was a
yeah yeah I just want to get to the
point where she opens the pickle jar
where's the pickle Jack it was a rigged
pickle jar it was rigged Tim look at
that oh look at this look at this she
looks like um
this is how crazy 2016 was I'm telling
you guys same haircut yeah like if you
weren't around for the great meme war
and salute to the great meme War
veterans out there if there's anyone's
in the chat you know who you are yeah
zero seven zero or oh seven oh seven you
see this is this is this is a fake news
at Play
because you know in this country and we
have a serious issue with pickle jars
that are tough to open they staged a
pickle jar opening to convince the
American people Hillary Clinton was
right person for it but you know what
the American people saw through the lies
and they knew she couldn't actually open
a pickle jar probably because she
collapsed on the side of the road had to
be thrown into a van now this was this
was before the collapse that's what I
mean this is what people were like they
saw three weeks before yeah this is also
a strange way to be like hey it looks
like you're having trouble you might
have weakness in your legs you're
getting fatigue please open this pickle
jar like they should have done the whole
interview standing if they wanted to
dispel the rumors but instead they're
like let's test out something else like
I don't understand if you go to the
doctor complaining of heart pain and he
checks your ears and he's like well
you're not deaf and you're like cool so
I'm fine like it it doesn't make any
sense to me I was gonna say in response
to the Elizabeth Warren um you know why
uh she apparently didn't get elected
Serena Williams announced this week that
she is like open to retiring and I
thought she did retire she is still
playing I think after this season she's
going to retire she said one of the big
things was you know one of her lines
from it was if I was a man I wouldn't be
writing this like her career because
she's talking about having more kids and
you know there are like some other
factors in her life she's over 40. I
think that a lot of women are told that
your problems come from not being a man
but I think what actually the problem is
is you're being pushed into careers and
into Lifestyles that don't allow you to
be female right like I didn't vote for
Elizabeth Warren because she didn't have
a penis I didn't vote for her because I
don't believe in what she believes in
but she's told actually if you were a
man you would have gotten elected if she
were a man with the same principles I
still wouldn't have voted for it right
yeah I still would have got thrown on
the bus I didn't vote for her because
she sucks I'm not voting for Dr Oz
because he sucks yeah I don't care if
he's a Republican and a man and all that
and that's all the right parts like they
just suck so who are you gonna vote for
then uh for that one I'm I mean I might
write in my dad like I did when my what
happens when Federman ones it then is he
even alive right we haven't seen this
guy in three he know he hasn't been on
the trail for three months oh he was
sick he was like seriously he has stroke
yeah he stroked out and he and he has
not been seen in public for three months
well you know yeah
he cuts these videos and he's like you
want to talk about health let's talk
about fetterman's health
um this guy like he'll he'll do these
videos with his wife where I guess he's
at his house
but when he talks it's all like it's all
wrong this beach is all disjointed
um but he does not seem well can you
open a pickle jar John fetterman open up
a pickle jar or else resign from the
race immediately yeah but I want to test
that pickle jar first yeah Ian's gonna
test that Ian will be the pickle jar
Tester the official one of Pennsylvania
I'm appointing you what we'll do is
we'll go to a supermarket yes Ian will
choose the pickle jar off the off the
shelf at random that's right and then
hand it but we have to make sure we have
to check it though because sometimes
little kids do it don't single people do
it yeah dogs with good senses of smell
to check smell the vacuum yeah make sure
that it hasn't no leaked bacteria
everything make sure it's still fresh
just check the top you press the top
yeah you just check the time my concern
with this Elizabeth Warren thing I've
been thinking a lot about hyperbole I
feel like especially with us doing a
show like being you know displaying
journalism and stuff it's real important
not to be hyperbolic the term all the
time gets used unfortunately way more
frequently than I like you can't get
used all the time yeah I almost said it
you see but I'm trying not to be
hyperbolic and this is Elizabeth Warren
saying everyone comes up to me that's
hyperbole some people probably have but
not everybody and it's like
we don't need to prove to people with
Zell that everyone and everything all
that like we're we made it now we just
got to be honest and be accurate
wouldn't she have been flying to was it
Iowa on a plane with the rest of her
campaign so she's saying she's talking
about the members of her campaign are
coming up to her being like if we'd vote
for you but not only that but we're
talking about her primaries so she's
talking about Democrats let's be fair
too obviously when she's saying everyone
she doesn't mean literally every single
person of course but even when we take
her statement at face value it's still
insane that okay obviously under staff
obviously not every single person she
meets but that there are women and and
old men who are like well I wish I had a
penis like I really just don't believe
that at all and it's no surprise that
Democrats do well it's kind of like you
know you also wonder if there's an
element of projection here where people
are saying things to her but in her mind
she keeps thinking that over and over
and over because that's her biggest it
she thinks that's her biggest challenge
I think she's and then she's talking
about over and over again that's what I
think is the problem a lot of women are
said like well the thing is if your man
opportunities would be different for you
and that's just like
in some ways you could understand the
logic but it's not the reality let me
let me let me explain to the ladies the
problem here
you see when you when you get
um when you get anti-meritocratic hiring
practices like in California did they
pass a law a while ago it's like the
board has to have a woman on it or
something like that
you're using this everywhere right so
you'll end up I've been in meetings like
this
and you have people I've been in
meetings like for documentary production
stuff and there's some women brilliant
and they'll say like here's my plan
here's what we're gonna do and I'm like
wow that sounds amazing like uh right
now we're working a documentary with a
woman and it's it's some of the best
I've ever seen uh Alex Moyer yeah I'm
just I'm like this is great stuff but
then what happens when you go into these
meetings where they've hired a woman to
fill a quota and then everyone's talking
and they're like
if we're going to sell more widgets we
need to improve the widgets and then the
the the quota a higher you know
individual regardless of if it's a woman
or not but but a lot of women will say
something that's totally out of line out
of context or doesn't align and people
have nothing to say but okay that won't
work okay but let's try something else
and then they go they're they're I'm the
only woman here and they're telling me
my ideas are no good that's it's because
I'm a woman and it's like no no it's
because you weren't qualified when you
were hired there are plenty of
circumstances I've been in where people
are we're all qualified and some men
weren't qualified and they were brought
on because they were the son of somebody
or something I've been in a ton of
meetings where it's like I'm like why is
this guy here like oh well his uncle
which which is and by the way if you are
speaking of female director I mean
Amelia's right so her father is John
millius you know world famous director
uh Red Dawn Conan Rome you know so much
stuff Apocalypse Now and a great writer
as well but she's had to to you know
come out on her own and but but she's
never come out and said you know I mean
it's a friend of mine but I've never
heard her once say something like oh
well I'm a female and you should let me
have this and oh my dad is so and so
it's like no it's I'm gonna do good work
and I hope you watch it the end you know
it's interesting I was just thinking
about being an actor the only time I've
ever really been Typecast for something
is when I'm acting and it's like I want
they're like hey we need a blonde male
that's 28 years old I'm like well that
was me that's perfect I'm so I
understand now Hollywood is so
identitarian and you see such nasty
propaganda coming out of that because
that whole industry is built around
identity and about finding someone to
fill the role for the character type
you're looking for not for who's the
best unfortunately sometimes you get the
best actor put into the role but way too
often so that that entire industry is
brainwashed to think this way and then
they affect TV and movies and then that
affects politics I think it'd be
interesting if we just started being
like hey look like you're okay you kind
of a background in whatever our
company's in but we need a woman to sit
at this table so we'll just pay you a
bunch of money to hang out maybe don't
talk that much like do you think anyone
would ever be like okay sounds good I've
got a family at home I'm just trying to
hear any money I don't think that sounds
horrible no no it doesn't but but what
this is all running up against and the
idea of a meritocracy runs up against
what is essentially the the Civic
religion in the United States and that
we aren't allowed to talk about the fact
that people are different that people
have differences that other some people
are smarter than others that some people
are more qualified than others that some
people are able to perform uh physical
tasks with greater ability than others
etc etc because we have this idea that
everybody has to be the same and that if
someone's a little bit different oh
don't say that because you're going to
hurt their feelings and this is
essentially the Civic religion in the
United States at this point is the way I
put it imagine you're on the third floor
of a burning building and there's thick
black smoke filling the air and you're
crawling on the ground and then all of a
sudden the door slams open boom right in
front of you and you're like oh save me
and then as the Smoke Clears a five foot
100 pound woman says I've got you I'd be
like oh situation not buzzing but now
imagine the same scenario and the door
gets kicked in and a six foot six tall
super ripped pure muscle guy goes I got
you you'd be like yes me I would I would
I would beg for a large powerful man to
be on the other side of that door please
a a large handsome chiseled bearded man
with bulging muscles specifically
handsome yeah it doesn't want an ugly
guy to save him no ugly guys no no my
point is like I don't care save me give
me function I don't care as long as it's
it look it could be a massive like well
wait hold on though but you're so
it totally got me on that one but
um but like uh but uh you know what
they're trying to add this to now
they're trying to bring this
you know non-merit hiring into airline
pilots
they're trying to push this now in and
saying it's not diverse enough
there's it's not female enough it's not
you know they don't like the they want
more
um you know racial and ethnic quotas
aren't enough they they're pretty soon
they're going to say it's not LGBT
enough or what whatever they're gonna
they're gonna start adding things that
dilute the pool of our airline pilots
which is just a job that obviously needs
to be the person who's best for the job
period no questions asked Jack I'm sorry
I'm sorry that that was incredibly
bigoted of you of you to say how many of
the uh airplane crashes have been have
been piloted by females huh not enough
not enough
there's actually a joke about the combat
dick go look up the Navy the combat
death Gap it's like 98 well go look up
some some games that's always really
bothered me that not enough women die in
combat I don't understand why you guys
aren't letting us serve our country the
same way hey man you see those videos
where how many how many oil rigs and you
know miners yeah there's the oil rate
would be much prettier if you let women
on it yeah maybe but there are those
videos where women were reacting to the
Senate trying to put women in the draft
and they were like I didn't know
feminism meant that no stop stop let me
just tell you real quick the the
military in this country is struggling
to recruit and you know what that means
it means draft so if something really
does crazy does happen and we get a
world war three or whatever they're
gonna be drafting you and ladies that
means you too equality right this is why
I was against feminism always if I get
drafted because of feminism I'll be
really mad what is this when's this
story from uh the 1990s oh the 90s oh
what's the story yeah a double first
female combat pilot died the very I
wanted to double check it I was about to
say U.S Navy this happened in the Navy
the very first and I was like I'm not
gonna say this before I I'm gonna
pre-fact check my I'm gonna pre-bunk
this I'm gonna pre-bunk this the first
combat qualified female Naval aviator
Aviator actually did die in a plane
crash I watched Top Gun there was a lady
in that plane bro and she did a good job
see here's my problem with top gun
Maverick
um my biggest the biggest problem with
the movie that everybody uh seems to
have missed I don't get it is that the
movie takes place in a country that
doesn't exist because it's as if the
America if the 80s never stopped and the
2000s never happened and yeah if if the
2000s never happened then sure you could
have top gun Maverick but they did
happen and so that that military doesn't
exist anymore especially especially with
the Navy after tail hook so what does
that explain so tail Hook was this idea
that there was this conference and they
busted a bunch of people NCIS got
involved and you had you know sexual
harassment claims sexual assault claims
many of which were true by the way but
the Navy's response to this was we are
going to basically
detestasteronify the entire force and
anyone with you know people get
sensitivity training and we have to
integrate the genders not long after
that was car holgren was pushed in as
the first female Aviator and and
eventually we're at the point now where
you have women serving on submarines
which never happened before
and this huge push against basically
anyone who had that sort of you know the
reputation of the Navy right the
reputation of the sailors got the girl
in every port and he's getting drunk
when they pulled in for you know a port
call or something and they wanted to do
everything they re reverted the force a
reward oriented the force completely
away from that towards this sort of like
you know the 90s modern male kind of
image and you still see that today and
you see you see that all the way up to
outside the Navy but
um the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff General milley where I don't know
if you saw his draft resignation letter
he was like crying as he wrote it you
know teardrops it was yeah we did a
dramatic reading on human events but
where it feels like it's I I can't allow
the military to be like this I can't be
a part of this you are you're
politicizing the military you were using
fear and I will no longer be a part and
I'm like this is using fire and iron and
this was
do you even understand why World War II
happened why didn't Trump fire that guy
because I I don't know drums have fired
all of these people fauci on down yeah
he's naive he he just just get rid of
him I don't know man I feel like I feel
like if anything that
Trump came into the situation thinking
that it was like you know Eisenhower
that it was the 1950s and when I'm the
president Bam Boom Snap My Fingers
something happens this thing gets nuked
these troops get pulled out from here
this this guy goes and gets blown up uh
this just the things just happen because
you're the president you order them to
happen without realizing that there's
this layer now there's this layer that's
called the administrative State and you
can use whatever you know he called the
Deep State you can call it the
bureaucracy whatever the idea is though
that and you go back to Woodrow Wilson
because he laid this all out exactly how
he wanted to Institute it that
when the darwinists first started coming
up when they said we we have organisms
we have survival of the fittest we want
the state then so Wilson reads Darwin
and says we need a state that is
operating under this model of survival
of the fittest and because the founding
fathers didn't know about Darwin they
didn't know about the Voyage of the
beagle they couldn't possibly have
understood the importance of the
survival of species and the importance
of the survival of the fittest and so we
need a new form of a state we need a
state that is organic that exists
outside of the branches of government
outside of Congress outside of the
people's Representatives who are elected
and so they came up with this new
bureaucracy the bureaucracy which we can
see nowadays is tied into Academia is
tied into education it's tied into
corporations and you see this idea of
the expert class which is Titan this is
how you get by the way you know an
Anthony fauci who's an unelected
bureaucrat who has power over our entire
country and all the people of congress
and many of the people the White House
completely just divert everything to him
and this happened in the Trump White
House for a very long time now event you
know people like Scott Atlas and others
got in there Peter Navarro was a big
part of this of course FBI is going
after him as well
and
that's what they're trying to do so Ian
when we were talking earlier about this
idea this idea that can the president
declassify anything
I mean
that very question is the way they want
you thinking they want you thinking that
the bureaucracy has power over the
president and that the president is only
given his power by you know the largest
and the generosity of that no absolutely
not our system is that the
commander-in-chief is elected by the
people he has the authority and they
have their Authority because of him this
is why if you saw the schedule F story
that axios was talking about uh Trump is
talking about that if he gets reelected
he wants to set up a situation where he
can just directly fire anybody in the
federal government and completely flip
this axis on its head that sounds good
so this is this is leviathan and
Huffington Post was going after me for
calling this but they didn't understand
what I was saying
um because I said Leviathan has woken
and they said oh sobik's saying Kraken
he said they put up like a picture of me
you know give me like side eye to
something
and said that I'm calling for war and
all this and I said no no no no no you
don't understand I'm referencing Hobbes
right so Hobbs wrote The Leviathan
Leviathan is the state is this
all-powerful super State and these
people that have been not elected not uh
transparently or openly put into
positions of Power by their people as
their representatives they just exist
because of their connections because of
their ties because they have to quote
unquote the right credentials the
opposite of a meritocracy you get a good
donation to somebody the donors yeah
like an ambassador right there you go
yeah I got mixed feelings on the can
fire anybody at any time Clause of
section was it called section f is it
why why oh because if you get a crazy
tyrant in there and they want to fire
everyone and then put cronies in that's
also you still have a congress
yeah the the the executive branch should
be under the command of the Executive
Branch the idea that we elect the person
to run the executive branch but then
bureaucratic civil servants block that
like the fact that Donald Trump was like
I want to get our troops out of Syria on
this and then uh this who was it it was
a McMaster who blocked it and said and
then lied about it right so uh that's a
problem that's a big problem we the
people said this is the guy for the job
um so they do all this in the name of
democracy by the way that's right rating
the rating your Chief political opponent
in the name of democracy I think that
Ben Frank will be horrified if the
amount of unelected power in the
American government I agree yeah I
completely agree all of the founding
people yeah if we if we attached a a
turbine you know uh uh to the the graves
of the founding fathers we would solve
climate change
yeah all the Tesla everyone would have a
Tesla after that yeah yeah a free car
okay
spinning body power yeah exactly well so
you think we should I mean do you think
a president could actually get away with
firing everybody or would they be like
actually
in in theory yes you can fire everyone
but
why shouldn't he
oh I mean de facto do you think it would
actually happen or do you think someone
would assassinate the guy
well I mean just from a practical
perspective I mean you'd have to do
rolling firings right you wouldn't be
able to get rid of everyone in the US
government at once sorry Libertarians by
the way
um I mean you technically could but you
but I do think it's the outcome you want
I do think it's funny that you get these
um when they do the government shutdowns
and everyone's like oh the government
shut down the government shut down and
then it's like did you notice yeah did
anything actually mean hopefully all it
meant is that like you know happen
people in the Army aren't getting paid
so how would you prevent if we were to
do a rolling fire of a lot of the
administrators say for something like
the bath party not to happen again how
when we went into Iraq we fired a bunch
of saddam's old party and then we said
you can never work in politics
we've got the bath party now that's the
end of state now that's my concern yeah
rid of the bath party when we fired them
all and said you can't work in politics
they kind of joined the talent yeah hear
me out you buy Greenland
you transfer them all to Greenland well
how do we stop them from forming like an
underground political movement is my
question what do you mean they've done
that but they're the ones in charge
right now and when you're looking at
Muller she wrote and you're looking at
the resistance and you're looking at the
attorney general just came out and
publicly stated that he ordered a raid
on the presidents the former president's
personal residence that's what's that's
the situation we're in right now I just
want to stress like and these people
didn't baton either they cheered it this
is something that in other countries
people have explained they've fled the
country over oh yeah when an
Administration comes in and then starts
arresting and raiding the homes of the
of their of their political opponents
there are people who are like that's
when I decided to leave the country it's
like we're all sitting here like well so
if you're in like a post-soviet state or
Venezuela or Cuba or
um you know parts of the middle the East
you're like oh yeah that's normal yeah
we know it's coming next like if we were
to fire or if the president were to fire
this modern iteration of the bath party
or whatever you want to consider it like
what would stop them from forming an
underground political movement of
violent extremism like the Taliban
because that's what they did in Iraq
they just kind of joined the Taliban
well we're not Iraq thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there